pas retrouvé à vesoul alain chrétien
députés les républiques en sortant
bonsoir à la chrétien vous ne vous
représentiez pas ce soir enfin du moins
comme suppléant de votre ancienne
suppléante marie breton est ce que ce
soir alors je le rappelle on n'a
toujours pas les résultats définitifs
pour la haute saône
mais vous êtes éliminé est ce que vous
payez clairement la division à droite
écoutez bonsoir à tous nous faisons un
très bon score sur vesoul un très bon
score sur et nous sommes en tête dans
beaucoup de communes malheureusement la
vague macron a submergé cette première
circonscription est clairement nous
subissons la division créée par alain
joyandet et michel raison qu'ils ont
sorti du chapeau l'assistant
parlementaire d'alain joyandet ya
quelques semaines uniquement pour nous
faire perdre puisque nous réalisons 17 %
des exprimés à quelques points du front
national on a on pouvait arriver à ce
second tour
malheureusement le candidat d'un âge
royan des faits seulement 12% alors
qu'il avait l'investiture de paris mais
on se rend bien compte qu'il ya quelque
chose de à droite qui ne marche plus à
haute saône
donc j'appelle aujourd'hui à la
démission d'alain joyandet de son poste
de secrétaire départemental des
républicains en haute saône
j'appelle à une refondation complète de
la droite parce que si on continue comme
ça
après avoir perdu les régionales je vous
rappelle que alain joyandet qui était
tête de liste aux régionales a fait le
pire score c'est ce score là qui nous a
fait perdre la région
il a tenté de faire perdre ma première
adjointe aux cantonales en 2015
donc maintenant ça suffit ça suffit il
faut que chacun prenne ses
responsabilités alain christophe était
inverse eux est ce qu'il n'ya pas quand
même la droite la plus bête du monde
excusez moi de parler ainsi mais
franchement c'est la circonscription à
droite dans la région c'était la
circonscription de perte de pierre
chantelat de christian berger l'un
d'alain joyandet de vous même
oui vous êtes éliminé parce que vous
n'avez pas réussi mobilise entendre eh
bien allez le dire à l'âge moyen des qui
est allé chercher son assistant
parlementaire pour nous faire perdre il
fait 12 % il fait 10 % vesoul dit est ce
que c'est parce qu'il ya un problème de
ligne océalis scène vous êtes un beau
chien alain guilbaud business 29
ça fait maintenant le maire voire de
cette circonscription alain chrétien
vous êtes tu soutiens d'aubry
aujourd'hui au gouvernement alors que
les autres parlementaires que vous citez
michel raison et alain joyandet eux sont
restés dans la ligne d'opposition des
républicains on va dire est ce que la
droite sait encore où elle habite ce
soir et est ce que ce sera le sado
tendre ou trois temps ne s'est pas cette
valse-hésitation n'a pas condamné la
droite aussi moi tout ce que je vous dis
ces questions nous avaient suivi en mars
à paris
et bien aujourd'hui on sera à 29 on
serait pas à 17
si on nous avait suivi on serait
aujourd'hui en tête dans cette
circonscription alain joyandet porte
l'entière responsabilité puisqu'il a
envoyé en campagne sur l'assistant
parlementaire pour nous faire perdre
donc aujourd'hui chacun doit tirer les
responsabilités de cet échec
on fait un bon score sur vesoul ont fait
un bon score sur et on est en tête dans
beaucoup de communes marie breton a fait
une très bonne campagne
c'est une fille de qualité elle a été
simplement torpillé par l'assistant
parlementaire d'alain joyandet c'est
tout ce que j'ai à dire ce soir mais je
suis là pour reconstruire avec tous ceux
qui le souhaitent une nouvelle droite en
haute saône
parce qu'on en a assez de ces erreurs
stratégiques qui sont faites par des
soi-disant classique mais aujourd'hui
deviennent des has been de la politique